l'accueil des jeunes d'origine étrangère
dans les écoles françaises dans les
maternelles de montfermeil en seine
saint denis cette injustice que l'on va
poursuivre le débat puisque le ministre
de l'éducation nationale lionel jospin a
demandé que des poursuites pour
discrimination raciale soit engagée
contre le maire de montfermeil monsieur
bernard alors ces derniers je vous le
rappelle avait refuser l'accueil
d'enfants immigrés dans deux écoles
maternelles de son côté aujourd'hui sos
racisme organisait une opération
symbolique mari michel martinet ces
enfants du champ sur le parvis de la
mairie de montfermeil sont venus en bus
du 20e arrondissement de paris dans leur
école surnommé l'école tout couleur des
enfants de 30 pays différents cohabitent
sans problème pour convaincre le maire
les enfants ont tenté cet après-midi
d'attendrir son coeur mais leurs
instituteurs et sos racisme veulent
surtout lui faire entendre raison
nous on est là on est dans une école une
école on sait l'école la république
c'est l'école de la tolérance et quand
je suis venu ici je me suis posé la
question est ce que le maire de
montfermeil à l école de la région des
cloches suicide ou alors il a raté
quelques courses n'est grand temps
monsieur bernard comprennent qu'ils ne
peut pas se placer au dessus de la loi
et qui ne doit pas à montfermeil
comme ailleurs décider de qui va les
croire sos racisme n'entend pas lâcher
la pression demain soir ils seront
encore là à l'heure du conseil municipal
à l'heure où les enfants seront au lit